welcome to this video playing and NM and
the saris and the Saracen probably it
pronounced somewhat different okay let's
see Queens gambit on yep I got a Queens
gambit okay maybe the Bishop f4 line can
can do something I'm really coming to to
rating ranges where I'm totally I'm
totally at the wrong place but at the
moment I don't I don't really have a
good good term streak am losing a ton of
stupid games maybe maybe this kind of
position can help to stop it at least
get a win in blacks position is very
passive you are h3 to preserve the
bishop in case of night h5 it's very
difficult and this position here for
black to to get get anything going
before maybe he can go before it's not I
should have prevented it maybe yeah he's
coming with Bishop a 6 it's not not very
very problematic but I could have played
played in a way that had prevented that
all right maybe that's 90 for now and
using using the square ok I'm going to
get the night to d3 on d3 at ctrl z 5
protect c5 and at a text before
attacking before is the most important
thing it's not so easy now for black to
cover the pond screen b8 is not possible
of course and the rookies on a 60 it's
difficult for him now to cover the pawn
yeah and now the B file is opened to to
White's advantage we just input the
rakia Knight b6 to get in here come on
lads let's play quick for a change oops
bring the Queen I can go here and play
rugby six I cannot believe that Queen
c4s any good o 95 was also strong even
stronger 95 was strongly when this could
have even prevented any sort of play
that black might have when here c4 I
saying c6 is saying and iruka saying so
here loose some material now
now this will loose material and
hopefully the game not winning this
would be very frustrating really out of
this position okay I guess just back
here because he six is still impossible
to hold okay this is a threat not really
am I can just take
black resign yeah it's losing losing all
pawns him yeah this was quickly going
down a loss though I probably it this
moment should have thought a bit more to
maybe before him maybe before almost
even even better to preempt e5 not sure
but ok this was played now it's not a
big problem the thing is with this
before move it makes sense with Bishop a
6cm but now what exactly is he doing on
the queenside if he takes and on a three
at some stage the B file is probably
opening to my advantage because the
bishop is always covering the b 8 square
so there's nothing can be coming to be a
to know rook or anything and it's not
clear what he's doing with the pawn on
before yeah here maybe five probably you
should go for this type of counter plane
may be here and then 93 I don't know
after this it's it's already very
substantial before a sum is basically a
goner or he takes and this is opening
the B file for a huge white white
advantage know yet yeah I'm winning
simply the back the better bone
structures is costing him the game yeah
here I could have played better yeah i
mean its wind in any case i guess but i
think the immediate 95 was even stronger
to even prevent queen coming anywhere
and then because i don't know where
actually exactly i only after that pick
up the pawn oops a little bit much but
ok this is this is winning all pawns so
it's it's really enough ok thanks for
watching